Philip is on the line in Charleston West
Virginia hi fella Pao are you sir I'm
doing good Dave how are you doing today
better than I deserve what's up Oh
they've I got a question about the
secondary employment I guess for yeah me
and my wife recently got married last
year and we've been working to get out
that they got the thousand dollars in
the bank but I I've never had to work on
Sundays I've always been blessed to not
have to as a Christian it's always been
really great for me but the secondary
employment opportunities where I live
all of them what they're people be able
to work on Sundays and I was wondering
as a Christian is it justifiable to work
on the Sabbath while I'm trying to get
out of debt as quick as I can
well it the way you're phrasing this it
obviously means a lot to you to be off
on the Sabbath on you and I share that
kind of a faith I'm an evangelical
Christian so I love the fact that my
buddies at chick-fil-a are closed on
Sundays I think that's cool and actually
there's fun productivity studies out
there that show that you're more
productive at work when you work six
days a week and so it turns out God had
a plan you know no shock to you and me
right any what about that yeah who would
have thunk it and so and yet I also hear
in your voice in the word choice that
you're using that you're not all twisted
up about this like you're afraid you're
going to hell if you work on Sunday or
something it's not a Salvation issue so
I'm not real legal istic about it with
the doctrine that I follow I generally
don't work on Sunday but I have it I
have at times um you know and if I do
it's you know seldom a full day in my
world I don't usually would be unusual
if I'm working on Sunday would be
because I'm preaching in a church these
days you know and I guess you'd call
that work but I guess it is and actually
not being paid for it so I don't know if
it's work but anyway but anyway the you
know so I I don't think it's a Salvation
issue I'm pretty sure it's not I'm
pretty sure it is God's best plan for us
to take time off and focus on him one
a week I think that's his best plan but
there's a lot of grace around it and so
I'm not much of a legalist on hardly
anything for that matter except work or
orthodoxy type issues when it comes to
doctrine but you know so I you know for
a period of time if you're careful and
you do it as little as possible and
you're trying to hit some goals for your
family I have and I don't think it
damaged my relationship with God
but I don't do it as a habit and I'm
certainly not doing it as a way of life
but I mean I know other people that work
every Sunday and they have Monday's off
you know and so they you know they're
going to choose the time they spend with
God and they set aside with God for a
different day of the week you'd be
really hard-pressed to prove it is
actually Sunday or Saturday the entire
denominational splits have been caused
over less I know that but oh yeah but
but when you go to church on your
Sabbath days yeah yeah that's how you
know that Saturday night church is
everywhere now so right and unless
you're seventh-day Adventist you know
that's not going to be your deal so
anyway it's it's interesting so I I've
just got a lot of grace around it so if
for a period of time you did but you
said hey this is not who I am it's not
how I'm going to live my entire life but
for a period of time to hit a particular
goal that's good for my family I'm going
to pour the coals on well I've done that
I've done that and I figured you might
consider that the donkey in the ditch
Claus yeah it's like it's that kind of
thing but again it's because I'm not
jesus said I am the Sabbath in Scripture
and so you get your rest and your peace
in him is what he was saying they're not
in a certain day but but it is it is
very valuable to take time off and to
not be a workaholic and you know there's
that that that's the other side of the
equation so to speak so I you know I'm
pretty lightweight about it but the
other thing is this I would leave it up
to you to I you don't need to do
something as Dave Ramsey said Dave
Ramsey's doctrine on this or Dave
Ramsey's doctrine on that that'd be a
bad idea
but if you feel if you feel convicted
that you shouldn't and you think that
that's not
some kind of performance-based
Christianity or some kind of legalism
but you think that's God's Spirit
speaking to you then don't you know if
God you feel like it's God's Spirit
telling you not to work on Sunday that
don't I would say that's conviction and
I would I would defend you to do that as
well so but if you're I didn't hear that
in the way you presented the question
and so I'll give you a you know between
two just regular guys sitting here
talking no neither one of us the
students of theology or doctrine right
other than have been a student of
theology and doctrine for 30 years but
aside from that but I mean it's not
we're not professional preachers you and
me so um we're just sitting there
talking I personally I don't think
anything about it but I don't regularly
work on Sundays either for that matter I
don't regularly work on Saturdays so
they're you know just there's another
thing by the way especially in the
summer time I'll be at the lake house so
there you go hey thanks for the call
dude I hope that helps you a little bit
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]